now the next body type is the old ovary
body type this is it right here see this
body type look where they gained the
weight lower part and the hips thighs
that's estrogen dominance take awhile to
guess why you don't see very many men
that look like that they don't have
ovaries very good so the ovary will up
produce too much estrogen the estrogen
makes fat around the superficial from
here down it will also make your arms
get big and the breasts get big I had
one patient
she was so estrogen dominant she became
a size H I didn't even know it goes that
high I thought D double triple D was the
highest let's see a b c d e f g h yeah
that's estrogen dominance how do you
know if your estrogen dominant if you
look like that and also you have heavy
periods cramping PMS all that guess what
that's going to do it's going to make a
fibroid I see so many women fibroids its
estrogen dominance so what's the
solution
cut it out I mean they're not doing
anything there are foods you can eat
right now that will balance estrogen
it's called the cruciferous vegetable
cruciferous vegetables are like kale
broccoli brussel sprouts cabbage all the
foods that no one eats those are very
estrogen they'd clean up the estrogen
they balance it and the chemicals thank
goodness we have those foods in our diet
if we ever eat them but mainly people
cook the heck out of them nothing so
estrogen dominant will cause anything
wrong with this cycle heavy periods
headaches that time of the month
cravings that time of the month
PMS how many of you know people that are
PMS okay I can see the husbands are not
like they're like
so you have all these different issues
that happen that time of the month if
it's cyclic because the hormones go on
waves just like all these circadian
waves fertility infertility because
estrogen you know it's really amazing
things you have this estrogen dominant
patient and guess what they give them
birth control pills but the it's the
exact opposite thing you're going to put
it more in estrogen dominance what food
should they stay away from soy why
because soy is very estrogenic and the
soy that's in America is not the same
that's another place it's not fermented
it's like it's just soy powder soy
protein isolates what does that do it's
going to grow tumors in your liver and
your in your where else in the ovaries
and the uterus it'll grow tumors it's
very trimmer producing yeah I see it all
the time there were even some men that
came in they were drinking so much so
amount they sort of lactating that was
enough for me to cut it completely out
of diet but there's estrogen is very
very bad for the liver and it's hairy
it's in almost lot it's in a lot of
foods isn't it it's genetically modified
it's almost hundred percent genetic you
modified in the US and that means they
alter the structure so there's a lot of
unknowns right now there's no studies so
the you know doesn't have to be on the
label to to be genetically modified they
could just stick it in there so you have
a soy it's in also in a lot of
prepackaged foods a lot of diets yeah
isn't it interesting the stuff that
causes estrogen is energized why did I
use it because it's so cheap it's so
cheap
I made a kale shake with I was going to
put some protein and the guy that was
helping me develop the for Mesa so you
got to put some soy and it's really
cheap like what I'm not going to put
that in there that's going to like kill
people so I put spirulina that's like
that's vegetate a vegetable sea
vegetable so it has some egg white
organic egg white and kale but the point
is that you don't want to do a lot of
estrogen with that because it want to
make sure if they're doing meats and
dairy
they have organic hormone-free this body
type craves dairy they like ice cream
cheese yogurt it's while they're trying
to get some hormones in there to try to
balance something because they're out of
balance and will never work though so
they have a lot of issues with that
and then when they get to be age 52 the
ovaries stop working okay but guess what
you have a backup organ here's the
ovaries the adrenals are little
triangles on top of the kidney these
start doing the work so now if the
adrenal glands are weak going into
menopause you're going to overload those
things and now this is going to do all
the work and so now you're going to have
all sorts of problems with hot flash
flashes night sweats okay does anyone
have a hot flash okay so hot flashes are
basically a short circuit in the
electrical system of your body that's
kind of like it's blowing that heat
right there someone's having a hot flash
right now so that would be hot flashes
so this body type ends up looking like
this body type after menopause so what
am I trying to tell you I'm trying to
give you a clue that you better do
something now before it's too late now
some of you in your mind you're thinking
wow I'm a mixed body type
I'm everything right you always have a
primary too much estrogen will block the
thyroid that's why when you get pregnant
you might end up with a thyroid problem
because the excess estrogen will block
this and then create all sorts of
problems many many borderline thyroid
cases need to take that red medication
when the pregnant because of the spike
of estrogen so all these things work
together if the liver is bad which we're
going to get to next
your thyroid can't work the your thyroid
needs that liver to convert like eighty
percent of all the activation of that
home
courser you liver so I had a lady she
came in she did the wrong diet for her
body type she did the high protein diet
okay she was a liver type liver types
should not do high protein diets okay
what happened she lost weight but she
also lost all of her hair
well she had two gray hairs she had a
wig a very nice wig um and she came in
and she said doctor we gotta help me I'm
like okay what's going on she goes look
at Shh okay yes we need we need to work
on that
so I said um what happened to you she
goes I just did this diet I lost all my
hair I said bingo you mess with your
liver and then the block the thyroid now
here's the problem she was going to she
was she was gonna get married okay
her husband future husband had no clue
she was completely bald okay that's the
situation when she would it's like it's
it's like the honeymoon night um honey
now that were married um surprise like
and then he pulls off his toupee I think
there was like a movie where you can
pull off your arm and your leg so I
worked on her I do a technique which
which works on old stress it's an
acupressure not puncture and we worked
on her and worked on the liver and she
got her hair back in three weeks tiny
little hair she came back she was real
happy got married never told them went
great yeah so these hormones have
dominating things dominating power to do
certain things we when you actually age
when you go from 20s 30s 40s 50s okay
hormones change metabolism slows down
would you agree with that you can't keep
doing the same thing with the calorie
counting you have to look at the
hormones in relationship to the
triggering of the fat burning hormones
I'm going to show you something before I
get to the next body type real fast
hormones there are three dominating
hormones
that if present in small amounts will
completely block and cancel all the fat
burning hormones okay in other words you
have two things you have things that you
should avoid and you have things that
you should do the things that you should
avoid are much much much much more
important than the things that you
should do it's the little step okay so
let's take this one the first one is
called insulin insulin is a hormone that
regulates sugar it decreases sugar it's
triggered by sugar so every time you eat
sugar it spikes the insulin okay you
become a diabetic and then sugar goes
high it doesn't go down so you have to
take insulin in the presence of just a
little tiny bit of insulin it can cancel
out and completely destroy all the good
stuff that you did so let's just make
this real let's take a cookie 80
calories you can walk that off in about
a mile but the sugar in that one cookie
will will block that burning for 72
hours if you have a slow metabolism like
most people do a half a glass of orange
juice a glass of wine unless dr. oz told
you do it which I'm just being sarcastic
because like wine is alcohol sugar it's
like it's going to completely block you
so we got insulin right it's the little
stuff that's going to really mess you up
so we have to we have to give you
substitutes for the thing you credit I
already know a habit is almost
impossible to break so we don't want to
take all the pleasure away from you in
life we want to tweak it so there's
things you can eat brownies for example
that have no sugar and no flour and you
can eat those you just have to know how
to make them and we have the recipes
we're giving you and you can actually
have it in the refrigerator and go for
that every night or when you when you
like that number two cortisol too much
cortisol that's the stress you're not
going to lose weight and that how do you
get rid of stress sleeping walking I
teach people to do an acupressure
technique which basically pulls the
stress that you do it before bed and you
just get into a good sleep and it
extracts the old stress
so cortisol will block fat-burning
that's why you have like when you have
physical trauma and then you have losses
loss of a loved one or divorce whatever
that will hit the drain a thousand times
harder than a physical trauma that's why
you have people that like after like
this major event they're just like they
never recover that's why you get
autoimmune diseases like lupus MS they
all come after losses okay so then we
have the last hormone that makes you fat
is called estrogen remember all this
hidden sources of estrogen it's in the
hormones in Europe people are thinner
than Americans in America we got girls
going to the menstrual cycle out earlier
larger breasts kids are fatter you might
say it's a lot of different things but I
think the hormones are really messing us
up if you now do you guys realize that
turkeys are fed hormones that's why
they're bigger they're huge right they
can grow and fast if you consume the
turkey that's been injected with a
hormone is it possible that some of that
residue can get in your body if it makes
a turkey a Butterball turkey
is it possible to make a butter ball out
of you a Butterball turkey idea welcome
to America you're in the wrong country
at the wrong time so some of these poor
countries they're really rich in
nutrients but they come here and they
just get that I see it all the time they
move to America I'm like you doing fine
till you moved here welcome to Virginia
so we have to eat and understand how to
fortify our hormones okay